The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: As it turns out, not
by coincidence, the Apollo
program that started after
Kennedy's speech was made up
of a few different elements of
things that had been sort of
percolating in the background.
And one of them was studies at
MIT on guidance, not so much
to the Moon, but to Mars, and
coming out of Draper's
laboratories.
So I wanted to say a little bit
about that story, because
it's an interesting story.
And it's one you may not have
seen quite in this way.
So what we've talked about
before and the inertial
guidance and all that
sort of stuff.
This is the sort of very clearly
posed paradigmatic
picture of him.
And during the Second World War,
they started making these
gun sights.
And one of them was called
Doc's Shoebox.
And then I think we talked about
that too, which allowed
him to sort of lead
the target.
You can actually see, if you
go into the front door of
Draper Laboratories, they have
this prototype that he built
in his garage, sitting there.
And then during the war,
as we talked about--
sorry, during the Cold War,
they built a lot of
different kinds of--
I'm going to skip
through these--
inertial guidance and
stuff, particularly
for ballistic missiles.
And a bunch of these guys,
including this guy here, Dick
Batten, really did some
fundamental work in the theory
of inertia guidance.
It was pretty much literally how
do I get a nuclear missile
to land on a Russian city, given
the gravity field of the
Earth is not uniform, and
there's a lot of calculations,
and we don't have a lot
of different things?
And then this group--
the guy on the left, his name
is Hal Laning and he was a
computer guy from the
Whirlwind group.
Milt Trageser is the guy in the
back there and Dick Batten
is on the right.
Batten actually still teaches
a course in Core 16 on
astronomical guidance.
Actually, he may not have
taught it this year.
That's more or less a course
he's been teaching
continuously since
1945 or so, 1946.
And if you've ever seen when
they send a probe-- actually
they just did this with the
Messenger probe to Mercury--
and then they sort of swing it
around another planet as a way
to get it accelerated toward its
goal, as opposed to just
sending it directly there,
that's actually an idea that
Batten invented.
It is now used commonly in all
these different space probes.
And they made this Mars probe.
And the idea behind this probe
was to go to Mars, take one
picture, and come back to
the Earth and reenter
and drop the film.
And this thing, which looks just
like the Mercury capsule,
is the film canister.
And they had also in the '50s,
they built the guidance system
for the Polaris missile.
And the important thing about
the Polaris missile is it was
the first missile that could
be launched out of a
submarine, out of the
Polaris submarine.
And was a major US, huge project
during the '50s.
And basically they wrote a very
short proposal, proposing
to use that guidance system
to go to the Moon.
And they were awarded a contract
August 4, I believe
it was, 1961.
It was the first contract of the
entire Apollo program and
it came to MIT.
Which is some indicator a, of
how important they considered
the guidance.
Like how do you get there and
how you keep from smashing
into the Moon, and how do you
get home and keep from
smashing into the Earth
when you get home?
And b, it was the only major
contract of the entire program
that was awarded to
a university,
and not to a company.
And of course, the president
was from Massachusetts.
One of the very senior technical
people, Bob Siemens,
was an MIT guy, a student
of Draper's.
He was essentially the chief
engineer at this point.
And a little bit like the
Radiation Lab, there's no
question that those influences
helped steer this contract,
which was a lot of money.
Although it was less significant
for the money in
some sense, than for
the prestige that
went along with it.
And it was sole source.
There was no competition.
There was no proposals.
It just came straight MIT.
And all kinds of companies
protested it to Congress.
And it turned out it was
fully legal, so they
never changed it.
But it was not for a
computer, actually.
It was just for this guidance
unit and it was over the
course of the project.
And remember, this is 1961 and
all they thought about was how
do we get there and back?
And they begin working on this
problem in seven years or so.
And the idea was that
the astronaut would
sit inside the capsule.
And if you looked at the stars
with the telescope, you could
basically align yourself and
align the inertia platform.
Remember the inertial platform
navigates with accelerometers,
which can be very accurate.
But what's problem
with doing that?
It drifts.
So it loses its absolute
accuracy over time.
So every once in while, you have
to realign it and retell
it where it is.
And you could align yourself by
just pointing at the stars
and knowing which way
is up, in what's
called an inertial frame.
But if you wanted to actually
navigate, you had to do things
or closer to the planet.
So you could look at particular
points on the Earth.
The obvious one, the easiest one
is measure the size of the
Earth, because as
you go further
away, it get's smaller.
It turns out that's not a very
accurate measurement.
But it is one way to measure
where you are.
The most accurate way to
measure it is star
occultation.
So that if there's a star that
passes by the horizon, you
note the timing of that star and
that gives you a very good
sense of where you are.
So there's a whole variety of
things-- is anybody into
astronomy here?
I never was particularly.
But last year, my brother
brought me a telescope that
has one of these motorized
mounts on it, where you can
sort of tell it what star it
is and it'll go there.
That's basically what the Apollo
guidance computer was,
where it would point out
different stars.
It had a little database.
And the database of stars that
was used in the entire Apollo
program was, I forget, something
like 100 stars long.
And it was one junior engineer
in 1962, came to the MIT
libraries and looked up all the
star coordinates and put
them in the computer.
And that's the one they used
all the way through.
And astronauts were then trained
to know which stars,
and they each had a number on
them, and they could align
themselves with the catalog
and make sure they were
getting there.
And eventually, they ended up
putting a digital computer in
it, which was a pretty radical
step at the time.
Because again, computers
were room-size things.
And this was a computer that
was briefcase size.
And for those of you who are
into computers, it looked a
lot more like a microcontroller
than a
full-up, general purpose
computer.
It was modest numerical
capability, but lots of I/O
and interrupts and things going
in and out, 16 bits.
And it wasn't actually a single
chip thing, like a
microcontroller today, but
it had a lot of those
characteristics, including this
interface for the crew.
And it tied into the
inertial system.
So you have this combination
of the gyroscopes, the
telescopes, the computer itself,
and this display
keyboard unit.
And this is--
actually I forget who this is.
I think it's Jim Lovell.
No, Jim Lovell's the next one.
One of the Apollo astronauts
operating this system.
And there would have been a
display keyboard like that, up
on the main console, which he's
looking at, you can see
at the top.
I don't know if you're
familiar.
Has anybody seen the Apollo
capsules down in the
Smithsonian Air and
Space Museum?
They looked very awkward
on Earth.
But they were easier in space,
where when they're launching,
this guy, he would be in the
launch position, and have his
back on the ground, looking
at this control panel.
And then when they get
into space, he
actually can move up here.
And this is actually 90 degrees
from that position.
And there's a whole station
where they navigate from.
And what they would do would
be navigate by--
again, they're not flying the
spaceship doing this.
They're just aligning
the inertial system.
And then once the inertial
system knows where it's going,
they type in where they want
to go on the keyboard.
And so every few hours or so,
the inertial system would need
to be realigned.
So it would point at where
it thinks the star was.
The astronaut would look through
these telescopes.
One was a sort of low power, for
getting the thing in the
field of view.
And one was a high power, for
the precision pointing.
And then he had these
two little sets of
toggle switches here.
One of them would just move the
mirror in one axis and the
other would actually rotate
the spacecraft around.
And between those two things,
they would realign the star.
It would usually be off center,
just a little bit.
And they would say no, that's
not where it should be.
It should be here.
And then enter it into
the computer
and say that's centered.
And the computer would take
those error corrections, in
what today we call
a common filter--
Batten was one of the inventors
of the common filter--
and then update its
guidance solution.
It turned out you could do
that very accurately in
getting to the Moon.
And in Apollo 8, this is Jim
Lovell, who is probably best
known for his commanding of
Apollo 13, a few years later.
But this is Apollo 8, where they
first flew to the Moon.
And here you can see
him doing it.
And there's the keyboard
unit up there.
And there was essentially no
real hands-on of the joystick,
flying to the Moon.
It was much more OK, we've
got our unit aligned.
He did this 200 times over the
course of the trip to and from
the Moon on Apollo 8.
This is where they orbited,
but they never landed.
And he realigned it 200 times.
It had very, very accurate
navigation.
And the rest of it would be OK,
here's where we want to
go, here's the velocity
we want to achieve.
And the computer would just
orient the spacecraft, set up
the big thruster to fire, fire
it, and then have the big
velocity change.
A bit change in how the
astronauts expected
to fly to the Moon.
Yeah, Sarah?
AUDIENCE: Is that a picture of
the Command Module or the
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This is in the
Command Module, actually.
AUDIENCE: So there was
a DSKY in both?
PROFESSOR: There was a
DSKY in both, yes.
So there were two identical
copies of the computer, one
was in the Lunar Module and one
was in the Command Module.
They had different software
running on them though.
And in Apollo 13, that turned
out to be a huge benefit
because they could shut the
entire Command Module down and
transfer the coordinates from
one to the other and keep the
inertial solution of where they
were in the Lunar Module,
while they powered down.
So they had a redundant system
without really what being
aware of it, in a certain way,
without planning it, although
they did sort of plan it.
And the interesting thing is
these were two separate
spacecrafts.
How would you do that today?
Well, you'd have some network
and you just say, copy the
coordinates over.
And all they could do there
was read it off the LED
display and yell it
down the tunnel.
And the other guy would
type it in.
There was no electrical
connection between two computers.
This is actually-- the picture
in the MIT Museum, behind the
prototype of the computer
that's sitting there.
It's Davey Hoag, one of the
engineers on it, just another
view of it.
Although it's a very interesting
thing here, this
was the original block 1 version
of the computer.
And the idea was the astronauts
would be able to
repair the computer in flight.
And it's sort of like, anybody
ever have an old IBM PC where
you could pull--
I guess PCs are still
this way.
You can pull the cards
out and put new
cards in them and stuff.
That was the idea here.
You'd be able to pull
the cards out.
And they actually talked about
the astronauts having tools
and soldering irons and
things to repair
the computer in flight.
That turned out to be a bad
idea because on a space
flight, and this is still
true today, the physical
environment becomes completely
contaminated with all of the
exhalations from the
human bodies.
And on one of the Mercury
flights, one of the
electronics boxes shorted out.
And it turned out there were
urine crystals from the
astronaut that had--
it was vapor I guess, that had
crystallized on the circuits
and shorted them out.
And so after this, they ended
up going away from this
in-flight repair and just
building one sealed box that
was completely hermetically
sealed, no possibility of
repairing it.
And how did they have redundancy
you might ask?
And the answer is they didn't.
They just tried to engineer
it really well, to
make it really reliable.
Anybody know how many on the
Space Shuttle to control it?
Five.
Five parallel redundant
computers.
There's one in the
Apollo system.
It never failed in flight.
This is another view
of that process.
Here's where the astronaut in
the Command Module can look at
the Lunar Module and
they can navigate
relative to each other.
So you could think in your mind
about all the different
possible combinations of looking
at the Command Module,
looking at the Lunar Module,
looking at the Earth, a
million different things
you can do.
And it was an supremely
flexible program
that they could use.
Here's another view.
I probably just like the
way they make these
drawings and stuff.
And you can see in all of them,
made by the computer
engineers at Draper, with
computers in the center of the
system and the astronaut is
like this minor peripheral
that contributes something
here and there.
Here's another one,
yet another one.
This is actually a view that's
kind of interesting to look
at, of the position error at the
critical moment where they
left the Earth's gravitational
field and they entered the
Moon's gravitational field.
And when they're sighting on
the Earth's horizon as they
get that far away, the
error is just rising
and rising and rising.
And then at this critical
moment, they switched and they
sight on the lunar horizon
with these three stars.
And you can see the error just
goes down almost to nothing,
compared to the later calculated
accurate value.
So they plotted this stuff
obsessively and
were extremely clear.
Actually, this is the
actual error.
That's the position of where
their orbit is and depending
on where you are.
And that was part of the common
filter problem is you
only want to take the sightings
to update the
solution when it's going to
really be better than the
noise in the process to do it.
And Batten was very good
at figuring out
when that would be.
Another view of it.
Here's the one in the
Lunar Module.
Remember, the crews
are standing up.
You can see them here.
Here's the astronaut
right there.
Again sort of considering
obviously this human and
machine computing thing
that I've been
talking about all semester.
Another view of the landing.
So I wanted to show you one
little clip about the software
for this, because it's actually
really interesting.
The entire work statement for
MIT's role in the Apollo
program is 10 pages long.
This is before it became
$140 million program.
And one line says, of course MIT
will provide the programs
that are required to run
them the computer.
And it doesn't use the word
"software." The word software
hadn't been invented.
And I'll show a graph
in a little bit.
By the end of the program, they
were worried they may not
make the landing on the
Moon because the
software wouldn't be ready.
So the transition I would say
between people bragging about
how big their computers are and
Apollo, was the beginning
of people bragging about
how small they are.
And then also the transition
from idea that hardware was
really unreliable.
But one of the things this
computer used was really the
first silicon chips, integrated
circuits.
They bought 60% of the entire US
production of semiconductor
chips in 1964.
It gave a huge boost to this
budding, very uncertain
technology.
And that made the hardware
actually really reliable.
And like I said, they
never really had a
hardware failure in fight.
But there were all kinds of
funky software bugs that they
kind of uncover and the
beginning of that software
could kill you too.
AUDIENCE: What was the
percentage again?
PROFESSOR: 60%.
So I'll play this little clip,
which is from a video that we
made a couple years ago.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So one of things
interesting about that is that
they wove this core-rope
memory.
And we started this class
talking about the relationship
of industry in New England,
and typically the textile
industry to the foundation of
MIT and how many of the people
who had founded that industry
were MIT's early trustees.
And here we are a hundred years
later, and the textile
industry which is essentially
dying or dead by that time in
New England, these workers are
still very much using those
same kinds of skills.
Literally, that software was
manufactured in an old textile
plant in Waltham, Massachusetts,
which still
exists today.
And also we probably mentioned
Digital Equipment Corporation.
They started in old
textile plants.
If you go today to Manchester,
New Hampshire or even Lowell,
you'll find high-tech software
companies and stuff in these
old textile factories.
So there is this sort
of site all of
industrial decline and renewal.
This is one model.
You can see, those of
you familiar with
microcontrollers, it looks very
similar to what you might
see today, all the different
inputs, radars, and sensors,
and things, and the outputs for
the Lunar Module Another
view of the system.
Totally fly-by-wife, so every
time any commands from a
joystick, which weren't used
very commonly anyway, they
always went through the digital
computer before going
out to any of the thrusters.
At first, the astronauts wanted
direct wires, physical
wires, to control the solenoids
for the thrusters.
But there are 16 attitude
thrusters on the Lunar Module.
And you can imagine trying to,
in these clusters of four,
imagine trying to control each
one of those individually.
It was just not possible
to do.
Here's one view that I like
to show from the Draper--
the instrumentation lab,
of no automation in
the cockpit, no software.
The crew is completely busy,
overwhelmed, doing all these
different jobs.
And then full automation.
They're sleeping and smoking
cigars and playing cards.
And all they have to do is
look at the abort button.
It's pretty much how the
launch happened.
And still happens in
the shuttle today.
There's no manual control for
the first part of the launch.
And the astronauts were
convinced they could fly the
Saturn V rocket by hand, off the
launch pad, which turned
out not to be the case.
And they tried to find a kind of
middle ground between these
two positions.
Another view of that
navigation flow.
This one is a little bit later
and much more sophisticated
than the earlier ones.
I'll skip over a lot of this.
That's the DSKY, the
display keyboard.
Another view of it.
This type of digit, anybody
seen those before?
There's sort of a standard--
you can still see them
today in some places.
They're called 7-segment
displays, because it's seven
segments of a number.
They're a little bit
obsolete today.
But they're sort of part of
calculators and stuff.
As near as I can tell, that
display was invented for the
Apollo computer.
There's one guy on the team
who claims that he did it.
And I've never found anybody
who claims that they did it
before that.
So this kind of numerical
output, which became an icon
of the digital age for a long
time, was created for Apollo.
Just beginning to see touch-tone
telephones.
Anybody ever see a touchdown
telephone?
Probably before your
time, mainly.
But.
Instead of dial tones.
And this was the layout of
the touch-tone telephone.
And although in the end, AT&T
flipped it upside down.
And the astronauts had a
lot of resistance to
typing things in.
Because again, typing was not
something that highly-trained
test pilots were
used to doing.
They'd consider that office work
and mostly women's work.
And now of course, everybody
types all the time.
But at the time, that
sort of work was not
their idea of fun.
This guy is the guy you saw in
that slide show, Don Eyles.
Here he is with Don Draper.
And I like this picture
because--
and it actually relates
us to some of the
readings for today.
It captures the sense that this
Apollo project was partly
a product of what was
really the '50s,
kind of Cold War mentality.
And by the time it came to
fruition in the late '60s, was
a whole different world.
In fact, if you look at the
naming of the Apollo capsules,
the first ones are called Eagle
and Colombia and these
kind of super high-brow,
patriotic names.
And then by the later Apollo
programs, the capsules are
called Snoopy and Aquarius,
and much more kind of
reflecting '60s hippies
culture.
And this guy Don Eyles, he
graduated from BU with a
degree in mathematics
in 1967, so two
years before the landing.
The Apollo program was already
beginning to wind down on the
engineering.
He got a job at Draper Labs and
he started working there.
And within a few months, he
was writing the code that
controlled the landing
on the Moon.
And most of the code was written
by him and a few other
people for the actual landing.
And he was 24 years old when
Apollo 11 landed on the Moon.
And he was basically a hippie.
He had long hair.
And he talks about, during his
lunch breaks, he would go out
in Cambridge to protest
the Vietnam War.
And then come back to this
super-secret facility that was
working on nuclear guidance and
other things and work on
the Apollo program.
And he's this great example.
And he's still around.
And he's friend of
mine these days.
And he comes to speak
in my Apollo class.
And he's actually
a visual artist.
He does photography downtown.
And of the way that, on the
campus you have this mixture
of different kinds of cultures
and different sorts of
politics, mixing very freely
on the campus.
And he never found any
problem with that.
And he did his job just fine.
And he worked at Draper Labs for
another 25 years until he
retired about 10 years ago.
This is an interesting
one because it
also shows you how--
this thing right here
is a paper tape.
And they would literally take
the code from the computer,
and very much in the same spirit
of the numerically
controlled machine tools that we
talked about, feed the code
into this paper tape, into
this big machine.
And it would automatically
position this frame over the
hole, where she's putting
her needle through.
So they did manage to automate
it somewhat, where all the
worker had to do was thread the
needle, wait for the thing
to move, and thread it.
She didn't have to look
up a binary chart and
then find it there.
So that work was becoming
increasingly automated.
These are some of the people
who were involved in the
thing, some of who you
saw in the video.
This guy Joe Gavin
was at MIT grad.
He just died, I think less
than a year ago.
And he was vice president of
Grumman when they made the
Lunar Lander and then became
president of Grumman later.
And these other guys are mostly
programmers of various kinds.
And they mentioned Margaret
Hamilton, one of the very few
women engineers on
the program.
Here's the manpower for
hardware, which peaks in '65
and goes down.
And then the software manpower
just goes right up and almost
swamps them by the end.
I'll just say a little bit
more about the landing.
The landing was the most
challenging part
of the entire mission.
And up until this point right
here, at about 50,000 feet, it
was entirely controlled
by this computer.
So all these programmers down
in Cambridge are sitting
there, watching it on
the big screen.
And there's a room full of
people like this size.
And each one of them has a
little piece of that program
that's written in.
And they're all sort of
contributing in real time.
While the astronauts are
standing there monitoring,
until about 500 feet.
And they have this very clever
thing where the computer would
spit out a number, which you
could see down here, like 43.
And then the commander, this
would be Neil Armstrong, would
look through his window at this
number, minus 43, and he
could look out and see where
the target point was.
And the idea was then he could
change the target point if he
didn't like where it was.
And this is another view
of what he might see.
So there would be that the
landing site there, just sort
of a passive heads-up display.
And he could actually jog his
joystick and just say, I don't
like that landing site.
I want to kick it over there.
It would move by a degree.
And then the computer would
recalculate the entire
trajectory and bring
them that way.
And he could do that laterally
and fore and aft, as many
times as he wanted in the
course of the landing.
And in some of the landings,
they actually did it up to 18
or 20 times.
And the idea was it would
gradually converge on a
perfect spot.
And the interesting thing about
that, which is sort of
the topic of another story, is
that on all six landings, they
turned that system off at about
500 feet and they flew
it in a more semi-automatic
mode, still
very much fly by wire.
But then the story of the Apollo
landings became, the
astronaut intervenes, turns
off this sort of balky
technology, which is landing him
in a crater, and saves the
day by finding the perfect spot
and bringing it down.
And it was not really an
accurate story because the
whole system was designed to
interact with the operator to
allow them to select the
right kind of spot.
But they all turned
it off anyway.
They just wanted to fly.
Actually Dave Scott, who
is an MIT graduate--
it's about a third of the people
who walked on the Moon
had degrees from MIT.
And I teach a graduate course in
AeroAstro with Larry Young
on this whole story.
And we often have the Apollo
astronauts in to
speak to the students.
And they'll tell you, they were
either Larry's office
mates or a few of them were
his master's students when
they were here in
the early '60s.
And actually tomorrow, Dave
Scott is going to come.
He was the commander
of Apollo 15.
And he's the only one who I
think gave a really accurate
description of what happened
in these last seconds.
He said, you can say that you
wanted to be in the loop if
anything went wrong.
But you knew that if something
went wrong with a computer,
you were dead anyway.
But I came away that whole
way and darn it, I
just wanted to fly.
And so they all ended
up flying it the
last 500 feet or so.
And then NASA and the public
and the press could all say
that sort of traditional
American values were confirmed
by these sort of cowboy
astronauts landing on the Moon
by themselves.
But actually there was this
MIT-designed computer there.
And it's an interesting story
too about MIT educations,
because the earlier crews--
Aldren had a Ph.D. from MIT.
And the earlier astronauts
were not
very academic engineers.
But gradually over
time, they became
much more highly educated.
And MIT, with the exception of
West Point and the Naval
Academy and Air Force Academy,
the service academies, MIT has
trained more astronauts
than any other school.
And it became increasingly sort
of de rigeur to have a
master's or a Ph.D
in engineering.
And those crews were much more
accepting of these advanced
techniques for the guidance and
much less interested in
just flying it on in
by themselves.
Alan Shepard, and we mentioned
his flight, he
commanded Apollo 14.
And he said, aah, if the
computer failed, I could have
just taken over and landed
by myself on the Moon.
Which is physically impossible,
because you're
looking at a terrain landscape
that has zero indicators of
how far away from it you are.
You could actually be six inches
or six miles and you
wouldn't be able to tell the
difference because there's no
trees, there's no trucks,
there are no highways,
anything to give you
a sense of scale.
And he had a problem with
his landing radar.
It didn't come in until
the last few minutes.
But if the landing radar had
never come in, he said he
would have landed it anyway.
And he probably would
have crashed, if he
had tried to do that.
They're actually using this--
anybody want to guess
what this is, what
this diagram portrays?
It's actually a model of
the lunar terrain.
So if you've ever programmed a
control system-- we used to
have this problem building
underwater robots all time--
and you want to hold
a fixed altitude.
If you're cruising along the
bottom of the ocean in a robot
that's programmed to hold a
fixed altitude, so it's
sending a sonar beam off the
bottom and trying to hold an
altitude, and then you go over
a hole, the vehicle is going
to dive down like this
and smash into
the side of the hole.
And same thing here.
If you're trying to fly over
a mountain range--
it's not a coincidence that
the site for the Apollo 11
landing was called the
Sea of Tranquility.
They found the flattest, most
even terrain they could find.
But the geologists who were
running the science
experiments, really wanted to go
into places where there was
a lot of geological activity,
so the terrain
was a lot more crazy.
And on the later flights, they
really did land very much high
up in the mountains.
And this is just a way, where
with five line segments, in a
very, very simple computer
model, all it takes is these
five line segments and like six
numbers, you could model
that there were mountains
here.
And then you expected the
terrain to go like that.
And the computer model could eat
all that stuff for lunch
and it would keep a very stable
trajectory and allow
you to go over the mountains,
and then land right at the
edge, which is what they did on
Apollo 15, and 16, and 17,
a very clever thing.
That's the view out the window,
of Aldrin's side.
AUDIENCE: When do you begin to
see the sort of the decline in
the pilot-orientedness
of the astronauts
wanting to control more?
Because the thing that your
lecture brings to my mind is
the book, The Right Stuff, in
which that's a big issue.
But clearly what you're saying
is over time, that declines.
PROFESSOR: Hopefully,
we're seeing it now.
After the Moon landing,
what did they do?
They started sending an
airplane into orbit.
It wasn't the wisest choice.
But it was because the
astronauts wanted to fly
something that had
wings on it.
And it's not a very efficient
way to go to and from space.
AUDIENCE: So was Alex Roland
right all along?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in some way.
But from MIT's point of view,
again building into the Bill
Leslie piece from today, the
Apollo program ends in 1972.
It has this huge triumph
in 1969.
And that's right when all
these protests end up
happening and the Draper
Labs gets spun out.
They were extremely offended
and insulted by that move.
And there is still hard feelings
about it today.
A lot of the people who worked
at the Instrumentation Lab
were happy to work on
a civilian project.
And one of the reasons they
liked working on Apollo was
that it was a non-weapons
kind of project.
And then they felt like they
got the bad end of the rap
during a lot of the
protests anyway.
There was still a lot of
military funding and a lot of
weapons work going on there.
But it's sort of this irony of
this moment when this part of
MIT has this world shattering
technological triumph in a
way, and then also becomes
the brunt of it.
And it just shows you again the
ways that all these things
on this campus and in
the country were
conflicted at the time.
And somebody wrote recently
that at the time it seemed
like the hippies and the Moon
landings were the furthest
thing apart.
One of them was the military
industrial complex and one of
them was this kind of Utopian
vision of the world.
But looking back 30 years later,
you can see they have a
lot in common.
They were both sort of Utopian,
futuristic visions
that never quite succeeded in
the promise that they held.
And yet they both influenced
the world in different ways
that people hadn't
really expected.
And that was true on campus.
So mentioned in their response
paper, I'm forgetting who,
about how it was really the
one moment there was major
political activism on campus.
There were other places too.
But in this entire story, we
were teaching you the history
of Yale University or
NYU or Columbia.
It's a very political story
the way the students are
responding to the currents in
the outside world and how
those things played
out on campus.
And it's a much more muted story
here for reasons that
might be worth discussing.
And in the discussion, it's
really remarkable and notable
this one moment in the '70s,
when it happened.
And whereas, I went to college
at Yale in the '80s and there
were students being arrested all
the time for protests and
occupying the president's
office and things.
It became almost a kind of
a cartoon of itself,
it happened so often.
Well, if you noticed in the
150th Exhibit, one of the 150
objects is a tape of the
Grateful Dead playing on the
front steps of the
student center.
And I think it was April 1970,
was that when Kent State was?
And the thing they write about
it, it was within a week after
Kent State.
And the campus was
extremely tense.
Everybody was very unsure what
was going to happen.
And when they played their
music, they were very aware of
that and really tried to make
it be a sort of soothing,
calming moment as opposed to
a fractious, contentious,
potentially violent moment.
And that's one of the reasons
Debbie chose it as part of the
150 objects.
AUDIENCE: Very interesting.
PROFESSOR: So that takes
us up to 1970 or so.
And then there's four more
decades to deal with, between
now and then, some of
which we read about.
The Cambridge recombinant DNA
story is in some ways very
much a continuation of
this sort of story.
Cambridge was, I'm not sure how
much it still is, it still
is a little bit, a very
left-leaning community outside
of the university, very
activist, very concerned about
these big, potentially
scary technologies.
That was very much the mood of
the time, was what is this big
nasty force of technology
doing to our world?
And MIT, it was pretty
easy for to become
the center of that.
And John Durant's piece shows
you how that played out,
arguably in a constructive way,
a very interesting one.
And then in '80s,
the military--
we talked about this a little
bit last time--
got very much going again
under Reagan.
And a lot of money came into
computer science and other
engineering disciplines.
But also the economics of
technology and the challenge
from Japan became a big issue.
That had a lot of influence
on campus.
All the while, biotech and
biology is sort of creeping up
in importance and
dollar value.
And then the Cold War ends.
Chuck Vest becomes president in
the late either '89 or '90,
'91 I think.
He became president right about
when I came here as a
grad student.
And the big question on
everybody's mind was what at
that point?
MIT is dependent on government
funding for so long.
Now that the Cold War is over,
are we going to just shrivel
up and die?
And the pendulum goes again.
Where do they go?
Back towards industry.
And the '90s is very much--
I mean the government research
support is always there, but
very much industry.
I remember Chuck Vest saying--
it was probably pretty late in
his presidency, soon before he
stepped down, in a faculty
meeting, I've spent so many
years cultivating industrial
sponsors, it's very difficult.
It's very time consuming.
I would be very happy for the
government to start up again
and support--
I mean it didn't go down
ever, as much as
people feared it did.
But it became less of a
percentage of MIT's income.
Then the financial crisis in '08
happens and the stimulus
package comes in,
more government.
And the government runs out
of money, less government.
So this pendulum
keeps swinging.
AUDIENCE: The periods
are shorter.
PROFESSOR: The periods
are maybe shorter.
It could be true.